uh covers uh the rise of peter thiel uh
in silicon valley and to a larger extent
kind of the the rise of silicon valley
itself as a power base you know uh if
you turn back the clock um you know 15
years ago or so or you know over the
last couple of decades you know teal has
played this you know kind of incredible
behind the scenes role you know in the
tech industry as um you know the first
outside investor in facebook kind of the
guy who really first you know was the
one to believe in mark zuckerberg um as
well as the uh the the leader the de
facto leader of this group called the
paypal mafia which is this um sort of
unofficial network of um you know very
influential techies that it also
includes the founders of youtube yelp uh
it includes elon musk it includes reed
hoffman um and he's and he's you know
just been responsible for a huge amount
of the development of silicon valley
over the last um couple of decades now
that would all i think totally justify
you know doing a book like the one i
wrote about him but but it's actually
more interesting than that because you
know starting in 2016 teal really
started to step out as this political
figure as you know one of the most
prominent and important supporters of
donald trump in may um 2016 he shows up
on the list of delegates for the
republican national convention gives a
speech endorsing trump that's you know
pretty well received standing ovation
and then donates a huge sum of money
just before election day and plays this
you know really i think pivotal role
both in the election of trump and then
also in the early days of the trump
administration and so i think those two
things together you know make for a
really interesting story because you
have both the the silicon valley power
story which i think is has been going on
and is going to continue to go on and
also this political story which is you
know major silicon valley figure you
know getting involved in this kind of
really interesting and unexpected
political development in the united
states
yeah you mentioned the the the political
side of it which might have brought his
name to a broader audience than the
valley but even within the valley as you
were saying there's a lot of bigger more
well-known names you mentioned
zuckerberg there's bezos there's musk
why is but you say he's they're rarely
the true idol of silicon valley can you
explain that part before we jump into
the political side yeah of course and so
there are um other figures like you said
that are maybe better known or richer um
or um or you know have have you know
also have followings um uh you know musk
bezos um uh you know mark zuckerberg but
the thing is that what i think what
makes teal so interesting is not just
the money or the fact that you know he
he was he is a very successful investor
he has made a great deal of money um but
he's had this kind of very super
important cultural influence and that
that's the thing that i think is
probably overlooked and that's where you
know his impact maybe starts to
overshadow the impact of even some of
those better known figures um so i'm
talking about kind of the way that
silicon valley companies do business
this um uh you know kind of growth this
this hyper growth impulse that we've
seen play out um you know over and over
again first with facebook then with uber
um then with all of these uh softbank
companies we see it in this in the ethos
of disruption we see it in the in this
idea of founders being this kind of
privileged class of um of citizen who
are who are not only privileged um you
know as
just as as sort of seen as special
people but but have more rights than the
average investor of course you know mark
zuckerberg having these super voting
shares and that's something that teal
set up and that has of course spread
widely so this is a guy who is yes a
behind the scenes player but he also has
a huge following he's he's exceedingly
influential among the people who
actually you know do stuff in
in tech every day
something i was interested in your book
was there's this um mystique around
being a founder being a coder kind of
rolling your sleeves up and starting
from the beginning and then if you're
lucky riding that to the stratosphere
but teal himself isn't a coder he
doesn't really get his hands dirty with
these kind of things what is he bringing
to the table that's bringing him this
much success so many times so broadly
well yeah i mean he doesn't he doesn't
have any particular um yeah tech
expertise um of course now he's been in
the industry for a long time and and i
think that is that's really interesting
and it raised a lot of
of kind of cool questions i mean he so
what he brings to the table is um he's
very good at kind of like predicting the
future and and that's one reason i think
it's worth um kind of paying attention
to him he's also very good at the kind
of chess moves of business of the kind
of you know how do you sort of
both as maybe as a leader kind of
conventional sort of he's well he's an
unconventional manager but but has been
successful at times um but also just as
somebody who can kind of knows how to
move the pieces on the chess board to
get what he wants um you know there
aren't that many uh business people
who've kind of gone toe to toe with elon
musk and come out ahead and i think
teal's one of those right teal during
the early years of paypal led a coup
where he you know he bested elon musk
got him tossed out of the company in
this totally um you know kind of
cold-blooded uh machiavellian fashion
and somehow managed not only to become
ceo of paypal but but sort of uh managed
to keep that connection with elon musk
and that is kind of a an amazing
instance of sort of just sort of
machiavellian gamesmanship and you see
that over and over again with peter
thiel and i think you i would argue you
saw it during the trump administration
you know i think he played that um
pretty well you know just from a sort of
tactical and gamesmanship perspective
maybe if not you know there's going to
be a lot of disagreement about whether
he played it well um from a political
perspective or from an ideological
perspective
yeah you mentioned the musk relationship
i thought that was really interesting
too i mean there was enough drama just
in that relationship to probably create
its own mini-series at some point and as
you know they're still
colleagues in some degrees today
how is he able to maintain those
relationships with people even after
they square off in pretty public ways
well i think okay so i think it's a
couple of things i think one is teal is
somebody who uh you know gets a charge
from sort of disagreeing with people
from being controversial um and so so in
some ways you know that's like just how
i relate to the world um i also think
that it's a reflection of his power um
as i said you know this this group the
paypal mafia which includes these
incredibly uh successful business people
um they are able to kind of move money
around to kind of act as as king makers
um both in terms of uh financing
startups but also giving jobs to
promising uh you know young people and
and they've created this following where
where there's a lot of power there and i
think um so i think there's to some
extent there's a friendship although
it's maybe more of a frenemy ship and
there's also a power relationship where
you know both of these men who are very
powerful kind of need each other and
they need each other more than they want
to you know fight with each other
if you're just joining us now we're
talking with max chaffin he is the
author of the contrarian peter thiel in
silicon valley's pursuit of power i
believe it's just out this week max
right i've got a copy here great yeah
yeah it came out a couple days ago uh
you can pick it up anywhere books are
sold
good plug you mentioned the future in
your last response that teal is pretty
good at looking into the future in this
crystal ball so to speak you wrote in
the book how he foresaw the the college
tuition bubble um protests against
google monopolies what do you think he's
agitating for now what do we have to
look out for that that he might be
interested in now that could be uh
foreshadowing something to come um so
there are a few things that i think are
worth paying attention to you know one
is uh crypto um you know teal is i think
in some sense you know the ideological
kind of godfather of crypto um back in
the day back in the the early years of
paypal um teal so we think of paypal as
just being this amazing you know money
transfer thing it's like visa but but on
the internet which of course it is but
it was also
and and really importantly part of this
kind of libertarian project that that is
a big part of peter thiel's you know
political ideology there are interviews
from the late 90s where teal talks about
paypal in these kind of revolutionary
terms this is going to be something
that's going to go beyond the nation
state it's going to allow people in
repressive countries countries where
they have currency controls to get
around those controls it's going to be a
swiss bank account in your pocket which
is like a really kind of radical thing
right for a ceo to say you know we
normally
you know most people are sort of
somewhat skeptical of you know the kind
of extreme privacy there's a lot of
complaints about you know money
laundering weapons trafficking etc when
you get into banking privacy and i think
that's important because that ideology
course transfers ex you know almost
almost mapped perfectly to crypto where
where like you hear crypto heads um kind
of talk about it in almost the exact
same terms and i think there's an
ideological debt there and it's
definitely part of of teal's kind of you
know libertarian world view and you're
seeing him you know make investments
both directly in crypto and also in kind
of uh crypto companies companies that
are kind of catering to this world um so
that's one thing i think uh the other
thing that's that's worth paying
attention to you know super closely is
teal as a political actor and and that
that that exists on a couple of
different dimensions um one of which you
kind of you hinted at which is google
right he's been um leading this kind of
at times over and at times like you know
somewhat i would argue some covert um
campaign uh to to bring scrutiny to
google whether it's scrutiny over
google's supposed connections um with
the chinese government scrutiny uh over
google's um uh supposed having a you
know a monopoly um and he's you know
he's been super critical and that of
course serves um you know multiple
functions i think i think probably on
some level the criticism is you know it
reflects his true beliefs right he's
somebody who despite having been a big
tech investor is um
has has been critical of of of tech
power but it's also you know from a
purely tactical perspective you know a
great way to take some of the heat off
of facebook where he's still on the
board google also you know competes for
government contracts with palantir where
where peter owen where peter thiel you
know is a co-founder and owns a ton of
stock still he's you know the biggest
shareholder palantir so there so it so
that that's a political thing that that
serves a business and there's also um
another political thing where teal you
know post uh 2020 is backing these kind
of hard right popular populist
nationalist um a couple of uh senate
candidates jd vance and blake masters
who are running more or less to be you
know the heirs to the trump movement so
so the the thing that people in the teal
circles talk about a lot is kind of
trumpism beyond trump or trump isn't
without trump and i think teal
is making a very explicit play to be
kind of the patron to that movement to
play the role you know that the koch
brothers played for a long time in kind
of mainstream republican politics um but
in this kind of trumpist uh political
movement that that is still going on i
think in in some
parts of the country at least is still
gaining strength
back to facebook for a moment i know
from from from reading the book that uh
still a big mentor to zuckerberg despite
some
it seems to be comment with him some
frictions along the way um and now you
have facebook trying to mint its own
coin going back to what you're saying
about crypto and his his ideas about
kind of perhaps destabilizing things
where do you see that influence going
with that project
well i think um you know zuckerberg has
talked at at some length about teal's
influence on him uh from a business
perspective you know as as having an
influence on on the way that zuckerberg
built the business and i think when you
look at kind of the the sort of peter
thiel business worldview which is you
know reflected in a book that um you
know basically every silicon valley
entrepreneur reads it's called zero to
one like you really see a lot of
parallels there um i think teal has had
an underappreciated
um influence on in terms of zuckerberg's
kind of political and ideological
outlook zuckerberg you know while he
during the obama years kind of styled
himself as a um you know sort of
centrist technocrat type um maybe maybe
not surprisingly you know there there
are definitely like libertarian threads
that run through facebook both in terms
of their kind of approach to to speech
and their and their um you know refusal
um to really you know crack down in a
big way on on things like misinformation
and and lies and in political ads um and
it also plays out in this in this um in
this currency project which of course
has a you know has you know business
implications for facebook and you know
if they're able to develop a you know
this this kind of crypto payment system
you know obviously that could be really
good for for the company and and and
make digital commerce you know
frictionless and um and do do lots of
things for for mark zuckerberg but of
course it's also kind of a continuation
this libertarian vision of this of this
idea of um taking power away from nation
states and you know people often observe
that you know facebook in some ways has
more power power than a country it's
kind of run like a country or maybe it's
run like a like the u.n um and i think
there is this extent to which like uh
the facebook project you know is is is
about transcending these national
borders and that includes um you know
parts aspects of social networking but
also of course you know currency is a
big way that um that governments um you
know regulate their countries and and
and this would um at least at the very
least complicate it and that's i mean i
think that's why you know regulators
have have have scrutinized it you know a
great deal and probably will continue to
scrutinize it where do you think teal
has the best chance at realizing his
vision is it through an increased or
prolonged influence over facebook and
where that's going given its complete
global reach is that he still got a hand
in the politics bucket at least here
domestically which is is it a race to to
his ultimate vision i mean i think teal
you know the i think the koch comparison
is helpful because um
the koch
approach is kind of like you know it's
part business and par politics right the
the there's a there's a there's a
company and that and a political uh
program and the political program kind
of advances the interest of the company
and the company feeds into the the
political interest and i think with teal
is pretty similar there's there's a a
political project which is this kind of
promotion of um
uh sort of hard right and at times
libertarian values um and and right now
it consists of kind of embracing this
this trump movement which i think
actually has a lot of potential for him
in terms of like playing the influence
game uh and then there is uh you know a
business project and that business
project is about you know uh growing his
um
you know growing his bankroll and also
you know uh
bringing new technologies uh to the
world and um and and you gotta remember
teal comes out of the hedge fund world
right he's very different from
uh from a lot of technologists in the
sense that he is not somebody who bets
it all on black or whatever on red
that's kind of that's a bit of the elon
musk approach um uh teal is somebody
who's always trading who's trading ideas
who's trading uh companies and i think
um so this is always going to be the
case he's going to be trying to find the
next trend um you know right now maybe
that's crypto also defense you know he's
got a lot of uh defense uh uh uh
investments so i think it's like he's
worth watching because you know if you
watch what he's doing you know you get a
little sneak peek into the future um
and and of course he's very smart at
kind of optimizing for his own um for
his own success whether that's
technological or or political
i've got a question here from the stream
daniel wants to know max did you have a
chance to talk to or interviewed hill
for the book and if not did he have any
reaction to the book so far of course uh
so i approached this you know there is
um
a lot like a huge body of of output
already on peter thiel and and to me
that was part of the attraction of the
project because
um there is on the on the on the left
teal is seen as this kind of super
villain uh on the right he's seen as a
superhero you know it's like uh he's
like you know an iranian hero who's you
know uh speaking truth to to power and
um uh
and and making the future happen and and
i and i was trying to kind of come come
somewhere down the middle right cut
through both of those myths which both
contain of course hints of truth but but
are not the whole story and so i you
know very early on um when i was
reporting this book you know approached
peter thiel um and had conversations you
know ongoing uh with his team while i
was reporting the book which included
you know interviews with more than 150
um sources who were you know in one way
or another closely connected to peter
thiel friends uh you know former
classmates uh people who work for him
people who work at his investment firms
and you know and so on um teal uh you
know kind of engaged you know and and
and uh and i met with him off the uh off
the record um but he did not participate
he did not speak to me on the record you
know at the end of the process we we uh
put forward a huge um you know list of
fact checking questions was which is
kind of like the standard kind of
journalistic approach um and uh you know
they they listened uh and did not uh you
know respond in any way i think we've
seen um
after the book's come out i've gotten he
hasn't spoken to me directly but but
i've gotten hints that he's he's seen uh
he's seen it or had at least at the very
least had had had the book described to
him or summarized or something like that
uh um and uh and has you know has issues
with it um as of course you you'd expect
um for when it's a a book that is uh
like i said not embracing the kind of
like the mythology um but i think i what
i think is that um number one
um you know there's a lot of uh part of
what i wanted to do is like i said go
beyond the mythology people have access
to peter thiel's um thoughts right like
you can there's he's written a very good
book that that that that people can buy
and and will um will summarize his ideas
their youtube speeches you know i went
really deep in his you know his writing
and his speaking um but what i wanted to
do is actually understand what's behind
the scenes and to some extent you can't
understand that by just asking somebody
like if you say hey how did you make
this happen or you know why is it that
you're so powerful uh you know a lot of
times people either number one don't
have a good answer or um number two you
know don't want to tell you because like
that's kind of like the secret sauce so
so um so that's you know that's kind of
where where the book landed and i think
in in some ways it's probably a better
book for that
you just talked about some of the the
body of work that he has out there
that's influencing folks we've talked
about him being earl mentor to
zuckerberg and other names that we've
heard uh but what about the the next
generation i think what do you think
that they're gonna glean from this
you've mentioned youtube lectures and
books etc um we've kind of seen the
first gen play out on this do you think
it's gonna be any different for this
next class so to speak of entrepreneurs
and
builders as i believe he calls them
coming up in the valley and elsewhere
well i mean i think it's still
playing out i mean teal has run this uh
fellowship the teal fellowship for about
10 years and it's
uh basically they they give a hundred
hundred thousand dollars to very young
people to drop out of college it start
it was originally you know you had to be
under 20 they've raised it a little bit
because they had kind of had trouble uh
in in the early years um but but of
course that is like a you know powerful
kind of um way to kind of create that
next generation i mean and to increase
you know to to sort of power that
influence network which is which is you
know real and and you know it's
definitely not shrinking i mean the
other thing about this and what i find
you know just super interesting about
this stuff so like i'm you know friends
and my my colleague and friend ashley
vance who works at bloomberg and you
know he wrote a biography of elon musk
that i love and um in that book you know
musk is in every scene right he's he's
like pressing the button he's he's you
know uh he's like saturday night live
he's scrutinizing he scrutinized and
i've been in meetings with elon musk too
he scrutinizes everything right he wants
to make the final decision on the bolt
that goes into the the you know the left
you know wing nut on the you know right
flank of this you know sideways part on
the rocket whatever and maybe more of
the steve jobs school of leadership or
even more extreme i think um and but and
and teal is the opposite right he is
somebody whose power is a kind of quiet
power and and and that but that also is
power and it can be it can be also very
interesting you know the the one of the
one of the interesting things about
about this is like once you have a
certain amount of money and you've
created a reputation for you know say
contributing to political causes uh that
that that you're lied with or or funding
like-minded founders you get to this
point where you don't actually have to
tell people um to do things right
because because you create these
incentives that cause them to do it for
you and i think that to some extent is
kind of the key to understanding you
know peter thiel's power this is not
somebody who
who is in the room he's somebody who
creates the conditions and in that sense
of course you know the paypal mafia to
call it a mafia is a cliche and it's a
little bit misleading because it's not a
you know mafias are violent networks and
that's not what this is but but one way
it is helpful is you know mafias work in
these indirect ways and that is and i
think that is very much the case um with
peter thiel and with actually you know
honestly how a lot of the influence in
silicon valley works if you want to get
a really good job in silicon valley you
know one way to do it is to kind of is
to court this this world by expressing
similar ideology similar ideas about the
future and you know praise for that for
their companies um and that um cuts
against i think a lot of the mythology
of silicon valley which sort of says you
know oh it's this amazing meritocracy
marketplace of ideas um which it is to
some extent but of course expressing
loyalty is its own path to success for a
lot of people
let's pull that sort of indirect
influence a little bit for a moment you
you've written about one of teal's
favorite tax loopholes that that has
something to do with this indirect
influence about over some of the
companies he's involved with can you
tell us about that i know it's uh
something we've been writing about on
bloomberg it's got a lot of interest
about how the wealthy are maybe skipping
out on some taxes through this method
yeah so thiel uh was a pioneer of um a
structure that is important to say uh
totally legal um where uh you know
basically uh founders of private
companies uh put shares of startups
which cost very little money when the
startup is founded inside of a roth ira
now roth iras were created in the 90s as
a kind of lower middle-class
middle-class retirement savings account
the there's a limit that's very
relatively low i think it was two
thousand dollars when teal began
contributing to it at six thousand
dollars now there are income limits if
you make more than a certain amount of
money
you cannot contribute to it to a roth
ira and what teal was able to do
basically is put a bunch of paypal
shares very early paypal shares into his
roth ira
and once you do that it's any gains any
income there is tax free so so that and
that money has grown and that then then
sort of rolled into other investments
early investment in palantir early
investment in facebook you know one of
the greatest uh you know venture capital
investments of all time was made inside
of this structure and what that means is
that you know teal now has an as a roth
ira that is in the you know in the
billions of dollars at least 5 billion
as of 2019 when you look at where the
stock market has gone since then and in
the market in general for private
companies you know it's probably
substantially higher now and so he's got
he has managed to you know avoid a tax
bill that that could in theory be in the
billions of dollars now um that's
controversial because you know because
of course like this lower middle class
middle class uh structure is now being
exploited by billionaires um of course
some people you know like it they think
and i think if you if you pin teal down
and asked him about it he would defend
it as a as as a legal use of the tax
code and also because you know he's not
somebody who's in favor of higher taxes
he's somebody who thinks that
billionaires should pay fewer taxes um
and that the the reach of the of the
state is is too much so so so there's
that the there is though you know the
prospect that the rules could change and
and in particular because um
these uh tech guys have been very very
aggressive in their you know in their
use of this in terms of buying shares of
their own companies which is technically
um okay because you're you're you're not
allowed to buy shares and a thing that
you control and a lot of these guys um
were buying shares in companies that
they didn't technically control because
when you're a silicon valley founder you
might own like 20 or 30 percent of the
company you might have two board seats
but that is not you know full-on control
but you could imagine a regulator or a
lawmaker
or an activist
making an argument successfully that
there was de facto control there um and
you know we've seen some court cases
we've also seen you know uh efforts in
congress to reign this in so i think
it's it's totally an open question
whether this will continue the thing is
um it's not it's not just peter teal
lots of other people have used this
structure um this would create a lot
this would this would lead to a lot of
mad billionaires if if uh if it changed
um and and peter thiel would be one of
them
i've got another question coming in from
the stream from a user named you can't
unhear this who's joining us again uh
thank you for your question again says
how did you decide when to end the
process of writing a biography of a
living person did you have any questions
you would like to have had uh that asked
teal but didn't get the chance
yeah you know that's the thing i mean it
is it is um uh the book is not it's not
a it's not a biography in the sense that
it that that teal's career is not over
it's it's maybe it's half over maybe and
you know of course
i i mean i'm i'm half joking but teal
wants to live forever he's he's um you
know he's he's done all this research
and life exception maybe it's only like
a quarter of the way over maybe baby
teal will live forever and what i've
just captured is just a tiny um slice of
his life but i think um i i i think it's
important because um
peter thiel has a lot of power and and
like i said it's it's a political power
but it's also kind of an economic and
cultural power and um i think it's it's
really
um good to closely scrutinize um these
things you know while they're happening
rather than just kind of waiting for you
know history to decide you know did
facebook uh or google have a monopoly
did face but you know whatever it's
better to be um just to ask those
questions now when when we can still you
know potentially take action or at least
you know change our own thinking about
it um so so that's i think that's kind
of the case for doing it now and i think
absolutely there will be an opportunity
you know for for more for more study of
this guy because i don't think he's done
i mean i think he's you know like i said
i think he's still making moves i think
in some ways you know his power is uh is
growing i mean the i i thought a lot
about the question of like well what
would i want to ask him if um
if you know if i could pin him down and
um i think one thing is you know he has
expressed affinity in various ways and
at various times for some very very very
extreme
um
ideas and those ideas include um uh
sort of a
skepticism toward democracy
um skepticism toward capitalism i guess
as we know it you know like he's
advocated kind of a sort of a vision of
capitalism sort of a monopoly capitalism
um and and uh and and skepticism you
know frankly to to this like the idea of
a nation state or whatever and and like
these are very
um very strong very almost radical
positions that um that i think a lot of
people you know on both sides of the
political spectrum might find a little
bit scary especially in somebody who has
a lot of power and and he hasn't really
answered this question hasn't really
said well do you actually you know do
you actually believe this stuff or are
you just kind of doing a contrarian you
know thought experiment thing and he's
he's allowed that ambiguity to hang out
there and i assume he will continue to
do so but i think you know pinning him
down on some of these questions would be
probably useful uh to us all as a
society
with that in mind what do you want the
biggest takeaway people
get from after reading this book to be i
mean the takeaway for me is that um
that
that there is a just just more power
than people appreciate in silicon valley
um and and that i mean teal is a i think
teal is a really
um interesting kind of case study in
that but it's he's not the beginning and
the end of that he's just he's just i
would argue the the most important
figure of it and i think that
scrutinizing um and asking tough
questions about of of these companies
and of the people who run them is um
what we all need to be doing both you
know what i feel like is important to do
as a journalist but i think probably is
something that citizens and politicians
and and everyone should be thinking
about at least
well if you want to think about it more
to our viewership at home max's book is
the contrarian peter thiel and silicon
valley's pursuit of power thank you max
for joining us today and thank you
everyone for tuning in and sharing such
great questions
thank you
take care